[dramatic music]
Seth, Steve, congratulations.
You guys have made it to this
final round of competition.
And that means we're sending
you back to your home forges
to recreate this iconic
weapon from history--
Napoleon's saber.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
Good luck.
Thanks.
[rock music]
SETH: I'm back home at my home
forge in Gautier, Mississippi,
and I'm going to be working
on Napoleon's saber.
Round one, I let the
pressure get to my head,
and I didn't meet parameters.
So I'm really going to have
to make sure that I don't
get flustered and make this
thing beautiful and functional
as well.
I decided to go with 5160.
It is a great spring steel.
But I'm looking at the
blade, and I think I have
a little too much curvature.
I was at the 3-inch mark, so I
had to put it back in the forge
and knock it down.
I knocked it down
a little too far.
Time to go back in
the forge again.
It's kind of like a
cat-and-mouse game.
It's a little over an inch.
Well, it's just one
of those things.
It's back and forth and back
and forth, and I finally got it.
STEVEN: I'm back at home.
I'm in my comfort zone.
The lack of power tools could
put me at a disadvantage,
so I need to plan wisely.
I've got a nice bar of 5160.
It's going to make a
good, strong sword.
It is super hard to hammer.
And I'm going to have
to just get after it
and know that day one
is going to be tough.
But I'm going to
have to suck it up.
We're going to be here a while.
For the pommel, I'm using
1-inch solid, hot-rolled steel.
I've got a lot of
metal to move, and I'm
a little bit worried
that I might not
get all this metal moved today.
Finally, I've got this
thing where I need it.
We're at the correct length,
the correct thickness.
Today is a success.
All right, feels pretty good.
SETH: It's the start of day two.
It's time to move on to the
heat treatment of the blade.
The idea is to get as even
a heat on this as possible.
And like Napoleon, I
will divide and conquer.
I don't feel no ticks.
I don't feel no tings.
I have a hardened blade.
It's time to do a rough
bit up of the wood part
of the handle and the pommel.
And this is going to
taper down to the brass.
That's the idea.
Now, is it going to work?
I go to try to bend it, and
it bends just a little bit
on the first go-round.
And I'm like, all right.
All right.
This looks like
it's going to work.
I go to try to bend
it one more time.
Oh!
Mm!
Broke the brass.
That was my biggest
piece of brass
that I could have
used for it, so
that's kind of down the drain.
At this point, I don't
really know what to do.
But I look down at
the floor, and I'm
looking at the deer
antlers that I have.
And I notice the
curvature in them.
No one says that
it has to be made
out of brass, copper, or gold.
As long as I hollow it out,
and it has a nice taper to it,
and it fits the hand,
why not a deer antler?
We got a fit.
STEVEN: Today we'll be
quenching the blade.
The quench is a moment
that can go horribly wrong.
I've got to get the entire blade
one nice, uniform temperature.
It's not going to be very easy
in the short forge that I have.
So what I plan on doing
is building an oven
at the backside of the forge.
This oven's going to
keep my point warm
but not let it cool off.
Should be a good help.
So I've got the forge turned
up as high as it'll go.
I've got my little butane
torch in the front.
All right, here we go.
We're straight.
The beautiful sound
of a skating file--
hard, hard, hard.
How'd the quench go?
Quench went good, I think--
no bends, no warps, got
it out, file skated on it.
I'm ready to see it finished.
Give me a little while,
and we'll have that done, OK?
OK.
- Thanks for checking.
- No problem.
Love you.
Love you too.
SETH: The closer and closer
I get towards the final shape
of it, I'm feeling it in my
hand, kind of twirling it
a little bit--
not quite as good as Doug
Marcaida will be doing,
but feels good in the hand.
Becoming a "Forged
in Fire" champion
would be a great way to show
people that I can do this
and would be one
step closer for me
to becoming a
full-time bladesmith,
because this is the
dream right here.
I am done.
I couldn't be happier.
STEVEN: It's the last day.
I tempered in the blade
yesterday in the oven,
but I felt like I
maybe half did the job.
So I want to temper
my blade with my torch
to give me peace of mind.
There is risk
involved in the torch
temper, which means that I could
lose the hardness of the blade.
I should see a nice
blue up toward the top
and a little straw moving down
toward the middle of the blade.
I think that Seth
is going to try
to design a blade
that's going to be much
prettier and sharper than mine.
But I sacrificed a
little bit of sharpness
to get a little more meat
behind that cutting edge.
I'm in at about 3
pounds right now.
It's going to cut, but it's
not going to be a razor blade.
It doesn't feel horribly heavy.
It really doesn't.
Put it right there.
There's one more thing to do.
It will kill.
MAN: It will kill.
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right,
bladesmiths, to find out
what kind of lethal damage
your weapon will do,
I'm gonna to deliver slashes
and thrusts on this pig carcass.
Seth, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Let's do it.
[rock music]
[blade impacts]
All right, Seth, from
the snotter to the trotter,
every cut with this,
as you can see,
offers a very deep,
lacerating cut.
The only issue is
that your blade did
pick up a little bit of a bend.
But overall, sir, with the way
this weapon moves and feels,
it will kill.
Thank you very much.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Good job.
All right, Steven, your turn.
You ready, sir?
Yes, sir.
[rock music]
[blade impacts]
All right, Steven, let's
talk about your saber here.
It's a heavy, unbalanced sword.
The minute you pick up, it
wants to pull straight down.
It's hard to wield.
But the weight of your sword
here will definitely bash
in and cut, so it will kill.
Thank you.
Well, bladesmiths, a saber's
supposed to be a sturdy weapon,
so let's see how yours hold
up on our strength test--
the ram skull chop.
Now, I'm going to take each of
your sabers and, with no mercy
at all, bash them
into this ram's skull.
It's not only going to test the
overall strength of your knife
but the heat treat on your edge.
Now, I don't really care what
your swords do to the skulls.
I want to see what the
skulls do to your swords.
Now, Seth, you're up first.
You ready to go?
Swing it good.
[rock music]
[grunting]
All right, Seth,
your edge held up.
But we do have a bigger bend in
the blade than we had before.
Your guard is now
mobile, and both
your bolsters came off as well.
So this mechanical
connection right in here
failed, but the connection
between your blade and
your handle is still sturdy.
You took some damage,
but you survived.
Good job.
Thank you, sir.
Steve, after seeing
that, how do you feel?
I don't know.
Let's see.
[rock music]
[clanging]
Daggone.
Well, Steve, we obviously
have a problem here.
You got a very coarse
grain structure in here,
so I don't know if there
was enough tempering
done on this 5160 blade.
I mean, one strike
is all it took,
and it snapped it right in half.
So that's obviously a problem.
Well, Steve, there's
nothing left to test.
Your blade has suffered
a catastrophic failure
and can no longer continue
in this competition.
And for that reason,
I have to ask
you to please exit the forge.
STEVEN: I'm upset.
I'm very disappointed that
the blade broke like that.
I'm not coming
home as a champion,
but I'm coming home
a whole lot smarter.
I've made some friends
that I'll have forever.
I would do this again,
no questions asked.
Well, Seth, this
is a competition
where the best blade wins.
Your blade survived
this strength test.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that's a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
How do you feel?
Surreal right now.
Well, good job, brother.
You're a champion.
SETH: I could not be more
excited about this experience.
This competition has been some
of the most fun of my life.
The money's going to do
some things for the shop.
And my wife and my
daughter are going
to go on a real nice trip.
Good job, Seth.
My name is Seth Borries,
and I'm a "Forged in Fire"
champion.